- [Instructor] We're
told, "Kason was curious
"if triangle ABC and
triangle GFE were congruent,
"so he tried to map one
figure onto the other
"using a rotation."
So let's see, this is triangle
ABC, and it looks like,
at first, he rotates
triangle ABC about point C,
to get it right over here, so
that's what they're depicting
in this diagram.
And then they say, "Kason concluded:
"It is not possible to map triangle ABC
"onto triangle GFE using a sequence
"of rigid transformations,
"so the triangles are not congruent."
So what I want you to
do is pause this video
and think about, is Kason correct
that they are not congruent,
because you can not map
ABC, triangle ABC onto triangle GFE
with rigid transformations?
All right, so the way I think about it,
he was able to do the rotation
that got us right over here,
so it is rotation about point C,
and so this point right over here,
let me make sure I get this right,
this would've become B prime,
and then this is A prime,
and then C is mapped to itself,
so C is equal to C prime.
But he's not done, there's
another rigid transformation
he could do, and that
would be a reflection
about the line FG.
So if he reflects about the line FG,
then this point is going
to be mapped to point E,
just like that.
And then if you did that,
you would see that there is
a series of rigid transformations
that maps triangle ABC onto triangle GFE.
So Kason is not correct, he
missed one more transformation
he could've done, which is a reflection.